But unless the virus is completely eradicated, which is highly unlikely,...
...there will be risks of it escalating to pandemic levels once again,...
...and factors like animals carrying and transmitting the virus...
...might undermine our best efforts altogether.
So, which strategy is best for this deadly, infectious respiratory virus?
Racing through it is a quick fix,...
...but would be a global catastrophe,...
...and may not work at all if people can be reinfected.
Crushing the virus through coordination alone is also enticing for its speed,...
...but only reliable with true and nearly impossible global cooperation.
That's why vaccination, assisted by as much global coordination as possible,...
...is generally considered to be the winner.
It's the slow, steady, and proven option in the race.
Even if the pandemic officially ends before a vaccine is ready,...
...the virus may reappear seasonally,...
...so vaccines will continue to protect people.
And although it may take years to create,...
...disruptions to most people's lives won't necessarily last the full duration.
Breakthroughs in treatment and prevention of symptoms...
...can make viruses much less dangerous,...
...and therefore require less extreme containment measures.
Take heart: the pandemic will end.
Its legacy will be long-lasting, but not all bad;...
...the breakthroughs, social services, and systems we develop...
...can be used to the betterment of everyone.
And if we take inspiration from the successes and lessons from the failures,...
...we can keep the next potential pandemic so contained...
...that our children's children won't even know its name.